albuquerque new mexico's small muslim
community is living in fear today after
the recent killings of four muslim men
now police believe that these murders
may be connected the latest happened
just friday night when a man was shot
dead after attending a funeral for two
other victims police say they are
tracking down the leads and they're
looking for a car that may be linked to
the killings madison connor of our
affiliate that's krqe has more on this
story
a community mourning a string of murders
now feels targeted and under threat
pakistani immigrant naim hussein was
shot and killed on friday the third
muslim man to be killed in less than two
weeks in albuquerque hussein was killed
by returning from the other victim's
funeral the attacks follow a similar
murder in november of last year when a
fourth muslim man muhammad ahmadi was
gunned down in a tweet sunday president
biden said he was angered and saddened
by the killings in what governor
michelle lujan grisham has called
targeted killings albuquerque's muslim
community is fearful of what may still
come
local leaders are trying to calm nerves
the message of hope is always here and
that is to defeat hate we will defeat
hate police on sunday said they have
identified this vehicle of interest and
officials including albuquerque's mayor
are pledging increased patrols around
mosques this is a frightening time for
many we have members of our muslim
community who are afraid to participate
this is where our city must demonstrate
a commitment
to try and make this a safe and
inclusive place in their time of need
among those living in fear of further
attacks is muhammad imataz hussain the
brother of victim muhammad afsal hussein
it's painful
we are in shock
we cannot go out of our house
my kids whenever i step out of my room
they start crying we didn't have any
fear now it is super painful for cbs
mornings madison connor albuquerque new
mexico